to that point of him using it or trying
to go out and hurt anyone with it
it was reported that he was potentially
armed
and then when the officers engaged him
he was armed and he engaged the officers
right and so it's important that we're
very clear
with that with that information where it
happened
how far into the school is it right by
the entrance
i i can't go into that detail at this
point just for clarification was the
shot fired before
officers engaged so
so again those details we're working
through
um and so i i believe the information
preliminarily
right and keep in mind all of this is
preliminary information until we get
more detail
right but preliminarily the subject
fired first
and then the officers returned fire or
the officer returned
all right and
are you guys prepared for any community
administration i'll leave that to chief
we're of course monitoring as we always
do um
you know we we remain prepared for
unusual and unforeseen events
so you know we are we are monitoring
what would you say in the austin east
coast tomorrow school
what would be the message that you would
give the families of the students when
they were going to school on thursday
you know we want kids in school we want
them in a good learning environment
we want to provide a safe learning
environment and we will do everything we
can to make sure that that happens
um you know it's again this was
unfortunate this is not knoxville this
is not the community that we are
and you know it's an unfortunate and
very sad
sad incident but hopefully not to be
repeated and we will do everything in
our power to make sure it's not repeated
one more question one more question fire
this weapon inside the school
those are parts of the investigation i
can't talk about it this time
can you speak to that yes the officer
fired
uh in response to the the the fire
uh the gunfire hit by that gunfire
that is still preliminary we're still
looking into that
all right thank you guys for your
patience and for coming out
a written statement has been posted on
tbinewsroom.com
if there are any updates and when there
are updates to provide
that's where the new information will be
posted so continue to check back there
also if you have any follow-up questions
after this briefing
and moving forward please send those to
tbi.media
tn.gov thank you